you're kidding me he said that to your  face to my face and then what happens I  get real close right I'm like I don't  care which Cabbage Patch  you're from oh give me back my  viewmaster before I knock the dimples  off your face you are I don't care bear  yeah you see the new movie trailer for  what you ain't see what what is it uh  key what they're making another Toy  Story movie now I thought those movies  were done dog they made three movies  didn't make three movies this is number  four Oh toy stories Martha Jane what  about Buzz Lightyear stuff I am Buzz  Lightyear Space Ranger and what is like  you to infinity and your mom that's not  right you sure no that's not right I'm  pretty sure that's it let me show you to  insanity and blonde what do you even hey  guys you got it all wrong it's to  infinity and beyond infinity this  impossible nothing about science  [Music]